when alligator dragged and killed a
woman after she tried to rescue her dog
from the reptile at a private south
carolina resort 45 year old Cassandra
Klein was walking near a lagoon on the
property of her vacation home yesterday
when the deadly attack happened mark
Strassmann is outside the gated
community on Hilton Head Island mark
good morning good morning alligator
attacks here in South Carolina are rare
about 20 attacks on people since 1976
frightening but generally not fatal but
this latest Gator attack here is the
state's second fatal one in the last two
years rare occurrence sad situation
investigators say 45 year old Cassandra
Kline was taking her dog for a routine
morning walk when the alligator attacked
when they got to this Lagoon authorities
say a nine-foot alligator came out and
lunged for the dog Klein tried to
protect her pet and that's when the
alligator attacked her instead it
appears that the alligator grabbed the
leash instead of the dog and it was some
sort of a basic tug-of-war with her
trying to get the dog back via the leash
and in in turn the alligator drugged her
and the dog into the water Klein's body
was recovered in the lagoon the dog was
not harmed people inside this gated
resort community were stunned by the
attack this is just gonna be
heartbreaking for everybody
Klein was an elementary school teacher
in upstate New York she and her husband
did not have any children and reportedly
split their time between New York and
South Carolina and a statement Klein
sister called her a special and
beautiful person
adding we are all heartbroken and not
sure how to get through this nationwide
deadly alligator attacks are
statistically rare but about two months
ago in South Florida a 47 year old woman
was killed while walking her dog in a
nature preserve her remains were found
inside a 12-foot alligator and in the
summer of 2016 2 year-old Layne Graves
was killed when he was attacked by an
alligator near a lake on a Disney Resort
property near Orlando people have
learned to adapt to live with alligators
there's water here there's going to be
an alligator in it
neighbors say this resort has had to
remove alligators in the past wildlife
officials were able to find the
alligator that attacked Cline and have
it euthanized John mark thank you